[Musique]
le nouveau centre d'incendié et de
secours de saint-andré a été inauguré ce
mardi 17 juillet situé sur un terrain de
4800 90 m² mise à disposition par la
commune
l'investissement total s'élève à 2
millions 929 1000 euros financés à
hauteur de 80 % par le département et 20
% par la ville de saint-andré le
département a mis en place un vaste plan
de construction de nouvelles casernes
fois les east la réunion en partenariat
avec les communes et aujourd'hui je suis
heureux d'être à saint-andré pour
l'inauguration de cette caserne 2,9
millions d'investissements une case yann
toute neuve pour accueillir tout le
personnel du sdiss ici à saint-andré le
plan khazen la construction de
l'occasion neuf fait partie de cette
volonté de donner de meilleures
conditions de travail aux personnels de
justice la réunion les 37 sapeurs
pompiers professionnels ainsi que les 60
pompiers volontaires de cette caserne
réalise près de trois mille
interventions par an il devenait
nécessaire de leur offrir de meilleures
conditions de travail
c'était dans des locaux vétustes on est
au cou qui offrait pas les des
conditions de vie correcte et de locaux
il était difficile de reconditionner
correctement et rapidement les dés
les engins donc c'est vrai que depuis
quelques jours ils ont une autre qualité
de vie forcément
par rapport à l'ancien centre de secours
ont pu vous voyez là ils ont un espace
je pense que vous avez pris quelques
images mais
ils ont des locaux qu'elle soit adoptée
mais aussi un espace de manoeuvre est-ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas dans leurs anciens
dans l'ancienne caserne
la construction de ce nouveau centre
concrétise la politique de casernement
arrêté par cyrille melchior président du
casdis ainsi que par l'ensemble des élus
du conseil d'administration
[Musique]